right there so what are we seeing
there imagine if this could be a plant
growing healthy like that in a
container imagine if you could enjoy
your fresh vegetables grown directly in
containers instead of a small backyard
garden so welcome to the
channel as we're going to
start there's that subscribe button
which is found somewhere at the bottom
of the video of your screen consider
subscribing so that you you keep on
getting useful information from back
gardening so what are we seeing
here this is a kale
plant not
planted directly in the garden but
instead planted in a
container so yes your kale plants can
survive very well in containers as you
you can see
here and this
kale was planted some time back it has
taken about 2 3 months now it is of this
size and if you consider the size of the
leaves and
consider the size of the leaves of the
kale plants glowing in the garden are
they any
different you can see that these ones
are even slightly
bigger but still from a kale plant grown
in
containers so it is possible to actually
propagate your kale plants fully in
containers so that you continue enjoying
your favorite vegetables if this is your
favorite vegetable for me it is my
favorite vegetable because I like so
much and I have to find several ways of
propagating as much as possible of this
vegetable which we call a
KS so this
container of course it's of average size
you don't need a very large container to
propagate your kale plants at Home in
your
backyard an average size of container
like this one can give you around two
plants per container but in this case I
just planted one plant and then the
other one was transplanted there later
to see how it will Thrive and as you can
see the effect of the shade
of this bigger plant on that other small
one has been uh very detrimental that
other smaller plant is not thriving very
well because of the fact that this other
bigger plant here was having a lot of
shade or was putting a lot of shade
beneath it and therefore the smaller
plant was not getting adequate amounts
of sunlight or light to facilitate the
process of photosynthesis within it
so in case you don't have enough land to
do a backyard
garden it's also possible that you do
container gardening just in your
backyard so that you grow your own
vegetables the way I've demonstrated
with this uh kale plant growing in a
container and of course remember for me
I always uh try as much as possible to
go organic so no chemical fertilizer
used here no insecticide no pesticide
used on this plant it's
organic with enough organic
manure incorporated into the soil to
ensure that the kale plant actually gets
all the nutrients it
needs from the soil where it's growing
within this
container what are some of the benefits
of uh propagating your plants within
containers one of the biggest benefits
is that you can actually move your
container around in case you want to
change the location of the container
from an area maybe which is not
receiving enough sunshine to another
area which is receiving enough direct
sunshine it's possible to move your
containers around within your
backyard and then the amount of water
that you need to uh irrigate your
containers is also not much because much
of that water will be retained within
the soil and some of it of course will
sip through to the bottom of the
container
where you have perforated holes to
ensure enough enough thorough drainage
through the soil within your
container and another big Advantage is
that uh management of pasts and diseases
is also very easy when you propagate uh
your vegetables within
containers it's not like in the garden
where the past could actually crawl
through from one plant onto another
easily with containers it's easier to
inspect the each of the plants and
then carry out past and disease
management practices because you usually
not have so many uh containers of
vegetables in your backet but just a few
to ensure that you have enough supply
for yourself and maybe possibly for your
family then another Advantage is that
each of the containers that you are
going to use it's possible to propagate
a number of plants within each of the
containers as long as as you time them
adequately remember if the plant grows
big and then you transplant another
plant onto that same container then the
shedding or the putting of The Shed from
that bigger plant onto the newly
transplanted plant on the container will
be quite detrimental and therefore it's
good that you transplant all plants onto
a a particular container at the same
time so that they grow at the same rate
and therefore they don't have uh that
competing factor for Sunshine once one
of the plants actually becomes bigger
than the other
one so those are some of the advantages
of actually propagating your vegetables
within containers in your backyard and
if you consider a small space like this
if I arrange like uh five containers or
even up to 10 containers those will be
enough containers to carry my vegetables
for consumption just locally as compared
to that Garden there where have planted
so much of vegetables actually those are
in excess to a good extent because I
usually share them with my neighbors
here but then if it's just for your own
consumption uh a few containers maybe
about 10 or about 8 to 10 sometimes even
up to 15 whichever the number that you
like can be suitable for you to
propagate enough vegetables for your own
consumption so it's not only KS which
can survive in container as shown here
you can try with any other plant that
you are so much um interested in or your
favorite plant that you may be
interested in
and within the comment section uh give
me uh mention of uh the plants which you
may have tried propagating in containers
or which you are currently propagating
in containers or which you may be
interested in trying to propagate in
containers so that we continue giving
each other tips on some of the practices
of growing plants within your backyard
for your own consumption and sometimes
even you can supply some of the excess
to the local market if it's within reach
or you can even Supply some to your
neighbors if they also consume the same
vegetables or same plants like you
do so give me a mention of uh your
favorite plants which you may want to
try out in containers or which you are
currently propagating in containers in
your backyard or which you may be
interested in propagating in containers
in your backyard at a later stage and
remember don't forget to subscribe to
the channel so that you keep on getting
updated content with the concepts of
buad
gardening thank you so we'll see in
another video again at a later time